today on the mat wall show Hershey's
becomes he she's as they appoint a trans
activist to be the face of their women's
History Month campaign that's not even
the worst of it we'll discuss all the
details today also some Republicans are
pushing to ban Tick-Tock as the ACLU
objects Tucker Carlson calls out
Christian leaders for their failure to
actually lead the most notorious groomer
on the internet keeps getting creepier
and creepier as time goes on and a daily
cancellation with women's history month
now upon us in Black History Month just
passed it seems like one group is being
left out we'll talk about all that and
more today on Matt Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
are you destined to outlive your savings
studies show the average person will
outlive their savings by almost 10 years
that's 10 years without a retirement
income when you need it the most or
those in those final years Bank on
yourself is a better way to grow and
protect your hard-earned money this
retirement plan alternative gives you
100 control of your money like you ought
to have Bank on yourself guarantees
predictable growth of all of your
hard-earned money with no luck no skill
uh or or guesswork required make sure
your plan doesn't go backwards when the
market tumbles and your retirement
income will be tax-free as well that's
the best part this concept allows you to
access your money for any purpose with
no questions asked and without
government penalties or restrictions you
can't do this with a 401k or IRA you
need this to do it get a free Report
with all details on the bank on yourself
strategy and how it adds guarantees
predictability and control to your
financial plan go to bankonyourself.com
Walsh that's bankonyourself.com walls
this information is for educational
purposes only and is not a solicitation
for purchase of any Financial product
all guarantees are based on the claims
paying ability of the insurer go to
bankonyourself.com wolves today
women's history month does not enjoy
exactly the same status as pride month
or Black History Month of the three
sacred celebrations women's History
Month which began this week is certainly
the lowest on the totem pole still it is
a it's an important uh and holy time on
the leftist liturgical calendar
especially because it presents yet
another opportunity to celebrate LGBT
people to be specific women's history
month is a time to celebrate men gay men
who masquerade as women that's certainly
um how the Hershey's Corporation sees it
anyway
that's why this week as you've probably
heard the candy company unveiled its he
for she Campaign which is meant to quote
shine a light on the women and girls who
Inspire us every day and they selected
five women to be a part of this so to be
faces of this initiative and each of the
women will even have their likenesses
adorned Hershey's chocolate bar
wrappings for the for the duration of
the month
but the interesting thing about one of
these women is that uh he is not a woman
at all but rather a man pretending to be
a woman trans activist Faye Johnstone
announced his inclusion in the campaign
this week with this video listen
my name is Faye Johnstone I'm the
executive director of wisdom to action
we can create a world where everyone is
able to live in public space as their
honest and authentic selves see the
woman changing how we see the future at
Hershey's Canada
now it's already as absurd and as
insulting as it can possibly get for a
major corporate brand to make this man
who by the way also looks and sounds
like a man
um a representative of women but
a glance at Johnstone's history and at
his social media posts tells an even
darker story
in fact Hershey has inadvertently
provided us with I think a very
revealing illustration of how trans
activists are made
and what they do with the privilege that
their self-identity affords them this is
not the company's intention to give us
this lesson we can assume that it wasn't
but they have given us this instructive
case study in any case
so it's worth I think investigating to
see what we can learn from it so
follow with me briefly as we go through
the story of Faye Johnstone
and we go all the way back to a few
years ago to 2014 and 2015. back then
Faye Johnstone then known as Zach
was posting on Instagram with hashtags
like gay boy and proud in fact he
even posted a public acknowledgment of
because at the time he identified as a
gay man and around that same time he
posted a public acknowledgment of an
apology for is quote CIS privilege
begging forgiveness for taking up space
as a queer male in that 2015 post this
is what he wrote this was Zach he says I
want to acknowledge my own CIS privilege
and say that across the board white
queer men like myself take up space that
marginalizes the most oppressed and
diverse members of our community
now it's quite a strange thing to see
yourself as merely taking up space but
this is what left us identity politics
entails if you're a white male
well then an interesting thing happened
after taking some women's history
classes and reading some feminist
literature and confronting his CIS
privilege some more all this is
documented on his Instagram Instagram
page Zach eventually decided that uh
well it turns out he's not CIS at all he
was no longer taking up space nor did he
owe any apologies over the next few
years he would identify as Femme and
quote non-binary and then land
eventually on trans it didn't take him
very long after discovering his non-cis
identity to monetize it
he put up another Instagram post in uh I
think it's 2017 advertising himself as a
professional queer quote-unquote and
seeking honorariums and paid gigs
magically John Stone was now in a
position to not only make money off of
this identity but to lecture the CIS
allies that he was just identifying
himself with like five seconds ago in
2017 he posted this
quote allyship means means taking
cisgender heterosexual spaces and making
them queer and trans-inclusive it means
not expecting trans and non-binary
people to have to educate everyone
around them every day and in every new
space it means being there and being
consistent
so many allies talk a big game but we
need you to do more than talk
this is a man who had once not long
before felt the need to apologize for
taking up space now he was blaming
others for taking up space that belonged
to him
how quickly can a white male go from
apologizing for his privilege to
scolding other people for theirs all you
have to do is put on a dress it's that
simple
and these days you don't even do that
much
John Stone wants the oppressor
was now you know once the oppressor was
now apparently the oppressed
and now it makes his living as a
professional activist he also takes full
advantage of the victim privilege that
he has claimed for himself as he
advocates for many horrific things
including putting Women In Harm's Way
just a few days ago John Stone
reprimanded someone for saying that male
rapists who identify as trans shouldn't
be housed in women's prisons he claimed
that trans identifying male sex
offenders must be placed in women's
prisons in the name of quote trans
liberation
the the separation of male and female
prisoners is not a solution he said
the Bears repeating here and emphasizing
a man who wants to lock women prisoners
into cages with male sex offenders and
violent rapists
is the person who her she chose to be a
representative of women for women's
History Month
it gets worse John Stone has also
explicitly advocated for vilifying quote
unquote his words
women who disagree with gender ideology
he said that such women turfs as he
calls them should be shouted down until
they quote don't dare to speak their
views publicly
and this is not new or unique rhetoric
coming from him back in 2017 he was
calling for quote militant queers to
rise up against his political enemies
nowadays Johnstone advocates for
mandatory trans affirming indoctrination
of children in public school a few
months ago he called for school boards
to establish quote Best Practices to
ensure all students learn about
accepting trans people
and as for parents who might object he
believes that as he stated that parents
don't have absolute rights over their
own children
now none of these Revelations are
shocking they don't even really count as
Revelations
I mean of course this male trans
activist hates women and doesn't care if
they're put In Harm's Way of course
all male trans activists hate women
because they resent and despise the
people who authentically belong to an
identity group that they covet but will
never really be a part of it's that
simple
and also they're all narcissists I mean
every single one
it's why they're transacting us
they care about nobody and nothing
except their own affirmation whatever
sacrifices must be made to make them
feel affirmed are worth it
and if that means that women have to get
raped in prison
as far as they're concerned they're fine
with it they're more than fine with it I
mean they hate women after all remember
the uh the militant rhetoric expressly
calling for the vilification of their
opponents
wishing to uh make their you know women
too afraid and intimidated to even speak
in public
this is also no surprise it is how trans
activists and LGBT activists have
leftist activists in general have always
operated
you know while people on the right
complain that my rhetoric is too mean
Too abrasive the other side has proudly
and explicitly set out to demonize
anyone who disagrees with them and
they'll even tell you that's what
they're doing
they're not having any conversation
about tone
okay there's no tone policing going on
on that side they all agree
whatever tone is necessary to harass and
terrorize the enemy is the right tone as
far as they're concerned
this is how they fight this war while
many on our side are still trying to you
know play patty cake with these people
it's also not a surprise
though very important to note
how Johnstone settled on his woman
identity in the first place I mean you
could track a similar progression for
nearly every young trans activist in the
country today especially since they've
all Left Behind extensive documentation
they've all left behind a paper trail on
social media so we can see how John
Stone came to understand
that he was the villain according to his
own ideology
as a cisgender quote-unquote white male
his role was to apologize and to step to
the side
he was a warm body taking up space
but nobody wants to see themselves that
way nobody wants to be that so over time
he came to see that there's a way around
this
he doesn't have to resign himself to his
position in in the caste system
all he had to do was declare himself
something other than male and a simple
declaration is all it takes
and suddenly he finds himself situated
at the top of the pyramid
moments before he was at the bottom
Pyramid has flipped on its head it's as
simple as that
it's really no wonder that trans and
non-binary identification have risen so
sharply there's lots of social capital
and also Financial Capital to be gained
from that identity and it only takes a
snap of the fingers to obtain it
now as for Hershey's
it's likely that the company didn't know
many of these background details when
they appointed Faye Johnstone their
spokesman or a spokeswoman as they would
claim
they uh you know that that certainly
isn't meant to be an excuse for the
company
not at all
the point is that they wouldn't have
done any background research or looked
into this guy at all all they needed to
know is that he's trans
and that automatically makes them above
reproach
and any attempt to investigate his
background or vet him or look into his
past statements would be an affront
against him
so I can guarantee you that they
specifically decided not to do that
this is what the law of Dei dictates
and Hershey's like most other
corporations is simply following that
law
and now they should suffer the
consequences for it
I mean we have to start really
penalizing these corporations for their
unthinking allegiance to this perverse
Twisted ideology nobody needs Hershey's
right we we could all go
the rest of our lives and never touch
another one of their products and and it
would it would require nothing of us it
would require no sacrifice at all
like it would not affect all the people
who are disgusted by what Hershey's has
done here
if all of us just said okay well I'm
never eating anything that Hershey makes
ever again
um it it would be a major win in the
culture
and also it would require it would not
affect our lifestyles at all we could
easily do it
and so that's what we need to do
now let's get to our five head
I believe in working hard for what you
have
um who do you trust to handle any and
all of your financial obligations if you
can't according to a recent poll 62 of
Americans who think about their own
death a lot still somehow don't have a
will that's kind of like being afraid of
drowning but refusing to wear a life
jacket it just doesn't make any sense
creating a will is one of the most
important things you can do to ensure
your belongings and your loved ones are
taken care of after you pass away my
partner said epic will can help you get
set up with a will today it's really
easy it's really cheap as well for just
119 in as little as five months epic
will can help you create your last will
and testament your living will and even
Health Care power of attorney go to
epicworld.com Walsh to get my discount
code and also save an extra 10 on your
complete will package with epic wheels
easy to use template all you have to do
is fill in the blanks go to epicwell.com
Walsh to save 10 on Epic Will's complete
will package that's epicwill.com Welsh
well to start with speaking of Hershey's
or he she's as we will call it now one
great way to make them pay for their
wokeness is to turn to the Alternatives
but what are the Alternatives well funny
you should ask that here's the report
from the daily wire
Hershey's chose the first day of women's
History Month to insult all women and
rational Men by introducing a gender
dysphoric man who claims to be female is
one of the faces of its commemorative
she-bar he even rolled out a social
media ad with Faye Johnstone gushing
about how she and other women are
changing how we see the future it was
too much for the daily wire co-founder
Jeremy boring who has built a reputation
for taking on woke companies and
offering alternatives to their consulted
customers already a razor magnate razor
and soon to be producer of wholesome
children's content boring is now a
chocolatier
is that what we call people to make
chocolate I guess so after after a
delusional Twitter users appeal to him
to offer another choice
fine Borg tweeted early Friday I'll do
it introducing Jeremy's chocolate yes
it's real we have two kinds he him and
she her one of them has nuts if you need
me to tell you which one keep buying
Hershey's
so that's the news this is a this is a
real thing that now exists that uh now
there is Jeremy's chocolates and you can
go to ihatehersheys.com and you can find
the website and you can find the the
options for the chocolate bar right now
looks like there are just the two
options but
uh if we learned anything from Jeremy's
razors we know that there will be many
more options still to come now uh you
know it's a it's a meme now
right on on social media that every time
a company goes woke everyone always says
oh I guess the daily wire is going to
make their own version
uh but it's not just a meme it's real
life we we are bringing the memes to
life here at the daily wire and I'm very
proud of that and it's a great thing for
two reasons okay one is like the obvious
one that uh that the serious one that it
is important to build alternatives
um
and
you know it could
makes it even easier on the consumer end
to
move away from these well companies if
those Alternatives exist
which is why we're building them
and it it should be really easy because
as I said even without the alternative
there's no reason like nobody needs
Hershey's
and so if they if we don't need you
we don't need you and if you're going to
come in and spit in our faces
then
I mean how much would we have to
how much
you know
disrespect what we have to have for
ourselves to continue buying this
product that we don't need and could
easily go without from a company that is
directly spitting in our faces
but it becomes all the easier when there
are these Alternatives that we have now
uh and now we have Jeremy's chocolates
but also number two the the second thing
is that it's it's it is great trolling
and I do think that there is a it
there's a virtue in in trolling I've
talked about this recently that
you know we can engage the left we can
fight back and you know
on many different levels there's
legislation there's you know of course
you have to make the arguments you have
to do all these things but there is a
real virtue of trolling too and of
mockery
because these people are
and what they represent is
uh it's it's what they you know their
ideology is poisonous and it's
destructive but it's also completely
ludicrous
and we can't lose sight of that
that's part of the trolling is to point
that out that's part of the mockery is
to point that out
and that's why there's a real value in
it
uh speaking of another thing we
shouldn't be using the ACLU is speaking
out against efforts to ban the Chinese
spyware app Tick Tock and here's a video
they put up I think on tick tock
talking about this and why it would be
an incredible infringement on Free
Speech to ban Tick Tock that's what they
say
Congress is trying to ban Tick Tock and
it is worse than you think here's what
you need to know tomorrow Congress will
consider a bill that effectively bans
Tech talk for people in the US and the
way that they're planning to do it will
undermine our first amendment rights for
years to come quietly introduced by
Texas Congressman Michael McCall over
the weekend the law would forbid U.S
citizens from engaging with entities
that may transfer sensitive personal
data to a foreign entity that is subject
to the influence of China effectively
Banning Tick Tock and many other foreign
businesses it would also gut the Berman
Amendment which was passed in 1988 to
protect our right to receive information
regardless of what country that
information was created in it's what
keeps the US government from Banning a
book by a Chinese author simply because
it's from China and in this case it
means that you can't ban a social media
app simply because the app is from a
Chinese company whether it's sharing cat
videos discussing spyballoons or
watching this video right now the first
amendment guarantees your right to
express yourself both online and off
this is what the uh this is what the
ACLU has become they're now coming to
the defense of communist China and the
technology that they've put out into the
world to spy on us and not just spy on
us by the way but specifically spying on
our children spying on and and
manipulating our kids which is what
they're doing with tick tock
you know we've talked before about
there's even a difference a very
noticeable and revealing difference in
the uh the way Tick Tock operates
in China as opposed to here
and kids in China use tick tock too but
they get a lot of like informative
wholesome you know types of content and
but here they get just absolute
depravity and filth and and and
stupidity
because Tick Tock is along with being a
spy app it's also a psyop against
um
you know
against our children specifically
and of course the claim that this is a
free speech thing is ridiculous uh on
the face of it because
you get rid of tick tock
you were not at all preventing anyone
from expressing their point of view
there are a million other social media
apps there are a million ways to
uh express yourself on the internets
like how many ways do you actually need
and on how many platforms do we have and
I say this is someone who's on 50
different platforms myself
um and I can have the excuse that I do
it for a living but even then it's still
excessive
but especially if you if you don't do
this for a living and you're just kind
of like a normal person with a with a
with a normal job or no job at all a lot
of people tick tock have no job it's
like what do you need do you need to be
do you need 50 different platforms for
kind of like saying the same thing
so there's no argument that this is a uh
that this is a an infringement on Free
Speech that'll prevent anyone from
expressing themselves
this is not an attack right on the users
of tick tock if you were to ban it
is to protect them
so if it's an attack on anyone or
anything it's on the Communist Chinese
government
so what are we infringing on their free
speech
now she brings up that well you couldn't
uh
you couldn't if a chinese author writes
a book you couldn't ban it and say well
no one's allowed to read it because it's
written by a Chinese author
and why can't you say that well because
that would be among other things that
would be you know an infringement on on
the author so but who's being infringed
on here
if the app is given to us by essentially
by the Chinese government so we're
infringing on their rights
on their rights to access our kids
uh
okay moving to this is a report to daily
Wire Fox News host Tucker Carlson
reacted on Thursday evening to the
arrest of a Canadian minister who
protested a drag queen event for
children Derek Reimer of mission seven
was arrested after he protested a drag
queen Story Hour at Calgary Public
Library on Saturday video shows him
shoved To The Ground by attendees as he
proclaimed that Jesus Christ is Lord and
quoted uh biblical passages about
homosexuality
this is what they're doing in Canada now
they're arresting people for that
Carlson also referenced professional
Christians who have frequently remained
silent on governmental overreach and
widespread disregard for biblical sexual
ethics
uh Carlson said where is David French
Beth Moore Tim Keller all these people
who are defending Christianity as actual
Christians are being arrested for being
Christian not a word I'm glad that he
brought this up because you know this is
specifically
on the issue of uh of
so the sexualization of children the
drag queen events
transgenderism gender ideology and I
have often had the same question as Dr
Carlson which is all of these uh
self-professed Christian leaders
where are they on this issue
I get this question a lot in Q and A's
and we're going around getting speeches
and I I hear this question for people
where are the where where's the church
on this issue why aren't they saying
anything
the actual leaders of churches why
aren't that's a very good question
and I think that this
when it comes to a litmus test for a
for a self-professed
uh self-appointed Christian leader you
couldn't ask for a better one than this
issue in particular on the gender issue
you know what because what we get from a
lot of these people David French is one
of them
if they're going to Wade in to this
topic it's going to be it's going to do
it's to do the tone policing thing
it's to say well you know there's there
there are excesses on on on that side
the people that are pushing their
excesses sure
but we have to be good Christians we
have to be nice and compassionate what
you don't hear them ever do is actually
take on the ideology itself
which tells you everything you need to
know about them all right one other
let's see make sure we have a lot of
we've several other things we don't have
time to get to
um
so instead we'll just go right to this
the uh you know the airlines are
celebrating women's history month and uh
here's a quick
Tick Tock another Tick Tock video this
one's from Delta in their women's
History Month celebration let's watch
this
did somebody say slay
[Music]
okay that was it that was the whole
thing so that was uh is a bunch of young
female Delta airline pilots and
mechanics and
flight attendants dancing and uh and lip
syncing
and you know you know this fills me with
visceral Terror I have to admit
um and it's it's it's not because I'm
sexist against female airline pilots
I mean I am as I've admitted but I also
want to make clear that uh that that
it's okay because I'm also ageist okay
when it comes to airline pilots young
airline pilots terrify me as well
as I've said many times every airline
pilot should be a man between the ages
of 40 and I'll say 65
and I believe they should all have
mustaches every pilot should look like
you know a version of Captain Sully the
land of the planet Hudson that that is
the classic airline pilot look and
that's what I'm looking for it makes me
feel more comfortable
uh I was on a plane the other day and
there was a there was a young guy in the
cockpit I try not to even look you know
if I when I'm walking in and the door's
still open you can see the pilots I try
not to even look anymore because I'm I'm
most the time these days I'm terrified
by what I see I happen to glance in and
the guy he looked like he was just out
of Middle School like this was his they
just took the training wheels off and
I'm on his first flight
and I get they got to start somewhere
but just don't start on the plane that
I'm flying on is my point
but my other issue with this kind of
thing is uh
this marketing strategy of Airlines and
you see a lot of this
it's not just like the wokeness it's
also the the lack of seriousness okay
what happened to seriousness in our
culture
I don't want an airline advertising
itself with lip syncing and dancing I I
just I don't
I don't I don't I don't want Tick Tock
videos from an airline I want a little
bit of seriousness cheerful okay you
don't want gloomy you don't want your
airline to be gloomy but you want
a a cheerful but serious disposition
from your airline I would say
that's what we're missing in our society
in general but especially
with Airlines
all right let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
again
[Applause]
common says late one night I was making
a doordash delivery to an apartment
complex there I encountered a young lady
who had ingested an illegal substance of
some sort and had a very adverse
reaction to it she was screaming and
rambling incoherently wandering
aimlessly and began removing her clothes
I was at a safe distance on the phone
with 9-1-1 to try and get her some help
meanwhile a couple of Knuckleheads were
nearby close enough to perhaps provoke
her further filming her on their phones
I yelled at them to keep their distance
this was not for their entertainment and
that uh and that I was trying to get her
some help shaking my head
um
yeah this is the uh it's they call it
the bystander effect and we talked about
this yesterday and that's there's some
comments pointing that out and this is a
this is something that's been observed
in human psychology since the dawn of
time pretty much
um
people when they're in
a
an unexpected situation potentially a
life-threatening situation you know a
traumatizing situation whatever it is
people tend to freeze and if especially
if they're in a group they kind of
freeze and they stand there and they're
they're waiting for someone else to act
but everybody is waiting for someone
else and so no one does anything
that's the bystander effect uh and I
understand that that's always been a
feature of an unfortunate feature of
human psychology I do think that it's
gotten a lot worse
and of course we are more aware so
there's always this question of uh
well are things worse in society or are
we just more aware of how things bad
things are because we can see it all on
video when in the past that was never an
option so there might be some of that
but I I it to me it does seem
like it's gotten worse
uh because of this technology that
allows us to see it it encourages more
of the bystander effect
because now people are also they're
taking other phones and they're filming
even in situations where
that there's no acceptable rationale for
filming now there could be times when
you someone could claim well I would get
this on film because it's important that
so the police will see it but so often
it's there's there's there's no value to
the video at all except as just content
the really disturbing thing is that
normal everyday people
because everyone's chronically online so
normal everyday people are experiencing
the world this way they they see the
world as nothing but an opportunity to
make content for the internet
and this should be that should be the
kind of Temptation that is really only
experienced by people like me who really
make a living delivering content and so
yeah that that's a pull that we can feel
sometimes that there's this uh need to
constantly churn out so much content and
so then you start seeing all of your
life as a as a as a you know an
opportunity to harvest more content and
um and then you know but so you got to
put these kind of barriers in place so
that you can live as a normal human
being
so I can understand when you're when
you're in the business there's that
temptation but you have people that
don't even make a living this way that's
still how they see it something happens
and the first thing they think is oh I
gotta get I got to get this on so I
gotta get this online
why
um
another comment says this episode Hit me
hard not only do I lack Communications
but skills but I'm also a lazy reader
always skipping through a bunch of words
looking for the main point also
everything I listen to has to be concise
well here's the good news we know that's
not true because you listen to this show
so that can't possibly if everything you
listen to had to be concise you wouldn't
be listening to me right now
um Talisa says the pink and blue thing
is real they consider dainty powder blue
to be a baby girl color and a more
robust red not pink to be for boys I
forget when and why they became swapped
but it doesn't answer the question
anyways
yeah but that actually shows that even
the associations of color with gender
are not actually entirely arbitrary
uh the color represents
right the attitude or demeanor that
Society Associates with each gender and
the association of the color to the
demeanor might be arbitrary so you said
well they they Associated blue with
being dainty back in the whenever in the
30s and now they we associate pink with
that well that part is arbitrary whether
it's blue or pink is arbitrary
um
but
the association of the demeanor to the
gender is not
so it's like everyone all societies have
agreed on kind of what feminine and
dainty and other like we associate that
with with with uh with women and with
girls
um but then we have different sort of uh
symbols
that are meant to to stand for that and
indicate that
um the symbols
might be arbitrary but the thing that
they are symbolizing is not arbitrary
and I think that's a fundamental
confusion that a lot of people have
these days
finally uh Final Fantasy says Matt needs
to go on to the whatever podcast he
would also be great on the
pbd valuetainment podcast
well on that ladder point I can tell you
uh stay tuned for next week
it's a little bit of a teaser for you if
you only listen to Media or leftist
activists you think changing your
identity as often as you change your
underwear is a perfectly normal thing to
do but if you listen to people who live
in reality like me you know the truth
but I'm not the only one pointing this
out in Jordan's new five-part series
vision and Destiny on daily wire plus he
articulates this better uh better than
even I ever could in fact it's a
psychological wake-up call that we all
need and just to show you what we're
talking about here's a clip
um to check it out
the idea that identity is subjectively
defined and that each of us is only what
we feel we are again whatever that means
especially allied with the notion that
that can change at a moment's notice
again as a consequence of subjective
whim is so psychologically Preposterous
that it's a miracle of stupidity that
it's ever been accepted at all
this is why our Jordan Peterson
Continental wire is so popular because
of insight like that and that's just a
little taste of it the third episode of
vision and Destiny is out today new
episodes are releasing every week but
it's all exclusive for daily wire Plus
members so you can join out at
dailywire.com subscribe to watch vision
and Destiny now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
we established in the open this is
women's history month or at least women
in name History Month there is also as
mentioned the recently concluded Black
History Month gay pride month but these
are not the only identity groups that
have their own nationally recognized
months of celebration for example May is
Asian American and Pacific Islander
Heritage Month September into October is
National Hispanic Heritage Month
November is National Native American
History Month we live in an inclusive
and Equitable time which means that all
identity groups are celebrated and all
people are encouraged to be proud of who
they are and of what their their group
has achieved and contributed to the
world right
well all groups except one of course
white males are not invited to this
party there is no men's history month
and there is no white History Month
which means that if you belong to both
identity groups then the only way to be
a part of the celebration is to claim
membership in a different group and this
as we've seen is a viable option for men
these days but it still leaves us with
the fact that you cannot be celebrated
while embracing your identity in your
actual group now all of these uh history
months are of course to use the
scientific term extremely cringe there
is a large part of me that would rather
make fun of the months than have my own
actually the entire part of me feels
that way still this is a microcosm of a
larger issue in our society in general
the message is clear every identity
group should be should be applauded
should be proud of itself should be
celebrated for its history and its
Heritage except for these two
and especially except for those who
belong to both
the months are just another thing
codifying this cultural policy you know
cementing it in place in fact this
Doctrine declares that white males who
even speak of their history or Heritage
or who say that they're proud to be who
they are proud of their identity must be
decried as bigots
that is if they simply engage in exactly
the same sort of rhetoric as everyone
else in every other group if they do and
say exactly what everyone else is doing
and saying no different
they are condemned no no no they're told
see if we do this it's good but if you
do it it's bad
and we're supposed to accept this
rationale they can't no one ever
explains it we're just supposed to
accept one of the many things that we're
supposed to accept
as if it's self-evident why every group
should be able to celebrate themselves
except this group
now it would be one thing if there was a
say a culture-wide push away from all
forms of tribalism I don't know how
plausible or even advisable this kind of
push would be there's never been a
post-tribal society and I doubt there
ever could be one
but it would be consistent if nothing
else we could at least respect the
consistency if not the realism of uh of
say messaging that said hey humans are
humans we're all one family we we
shouldn't be dividing ourselves into
groups or singling groups out for
special commendations or condemnations
uh it doesn't make any sense to be proud
of or celebrated for the identity that
you were born into you should be proud
of uh what you yourself have achieved
individually and proud of others for
what they've achieved regardless of
their race or gender We Are All One
Kumbaya et cetera Etc yada yada
now say what you want about this kind of
talk
it would at least be sincere if it was
applied to everyone but it isn't These
Warnings against tribalism are only
issued to white people and men and white
men in particular if a white man says
I'm proud to be a white man
then he's told that such talk makes no
sense and uh and so on and so on but if
anyone in any other group says I'm proud
to be in this identity group he's
applauded for his positive attitude
but the thing is that when only one
group is warned against tribalism
that is a form of tribalism itself it is
a tribalism where all the other groups
say to the hated group you have no tribe
you have no identity
you are in the words of our friend Faye
Johnstone just bodies taking up space
now this kind of message is a real
problem for many reasons and we'll just
talk about one of them
it is simply true that men have achieved
many great things
white people have achieved many great
things and white men have achieved many
great things the refusal to acknowledge
this and to acknowledge it specifically
actually say that white men have
achieved many great things and to
acknowledge it in the same way that we
acknowledge the achievements of black
people and women and so on
this has led to the widespread
impression that in fact white men have
done very little
this is the impression that our cultural
Elites want us to have when kids are
constantly told Hey listen to all the
great things that black people have done
and women have done and Hispanics have
done but they're never ever ever told
Hey listen to all the great things white
men have done
the kids will come to believe that white
men haven't done much at all
in fact you'll often hear this kind of
reasoning offered by uh by people who
are trying to defend our cultural
prohibition of white pride and male
pride and white history month and men's
history month so just one example I
Googled men's History Month
um just for the sake of it the very
first thing that popped up
was an article from a group called
parents together
and it was an article that like like
many others you could pick any at random
they're all they all kind of say the
same thing and this article is trying to
explain why you know there's no men's
history month and why there shouldn't be
one even though there is a women's
history month and the reason one of the
reasons they offered is this they said
this
the truth is that women have achieved
plenty throughout history but men often
got credit for their work here are just
a couple of examples female scientist
Rosalind Franklin was the first to
photograph uh the Double Helix structure
of DNA but two male researchers used her
work without permission and won awards
for the discovery female R B singer Big
Mama Thornton was the first to record
the song Hound Dog when Elvis Presley
later covered the song it became his
number one hit selling millions of
copies worldwide and helping him become
the ultra famous king of rock and roll
Okay so
we hear this kind of thing all the time
that white men were thieves they stole
the achievements from other identity
groups
but the people who make this claim can
only ever provide a few very dubious uh
examples
and that's because in reality
white men were and still are
indispensable
to our civilization
which is an understatement
a huge percentage of the greatest
inventors explorers discoverers
scientists philosophers political
leaders artists authors poets Pioneers
who built this country and this
civilization
or white or men and very often or both
and not because they stole the work of
others or they claimed credit for what
others have done but because they did it
they achieved it they built it and they
passed it down to us
this is simply a fact that should be
acknowledged just like it's acknowledged
for every other group but it's a fact
that many in our society especially
younger people actually don't know
because we're not allowed to
specifically acknowledge it
kids grow up with resentment and
suspicion towards white men
um rather than gratitude and it the the
kind of gratitude they should have
in fact this attitude is so ingrained it
is so pervasive it is so poisonous that
for me to even say that they should have
gratitude will be considered incredibly
sexist and racist everything I'm saying
right now is guaranteed to end up on
Twitter with people expressing outrage
and derision grateful for white men how
could you say such a thing
even though they would have no problem
and would applaud me if I said we should
be grateful for any other group of
people let's be grateful for black for
black Americans let's be grateful for
women let's be grateful for Native
Americans let's be grateful for
non-binary polyamorous Mexican Eskimos
all of that would be met with approval
but then if you add and let's be
grateful for white men
shock and shrieks of heart
uh this is again a real problem and it
really matters
it's not about merely pointing out a
double standard
okay because this is not just a double
standard it's about pointing out a real
and extremely successful effort to
demonize a certain group of people and
to erase their achievements we hear so
much about the groups of people being
erased in their achievements that's only
actually happening to one group and that
is white men okay the only group of
people that in this country that are
being erased and in any kind of
meaningful way
um historically are white men
and then people that are being erased in
uh in another sense women by by the the
trans activists
so those are the those are the two ways
in which people are erased in this
culture and uh but those are also the
ways that are never acknowledged
we are not the first Society to single
out a group this way we won't be the
last
and that's why you know we know where it
leads and we know that it doesn't lead
anywhere good
and that is why today
in women's History Month
the effort to cancel white men is
instead canceled
that'll do it for today and for the week
we'll talk to you on Monday have a great
weekend great weekend Godspeed
[Music]
the executive producer of the Matt wall
show is Sean Hampton our associate
producer is McKenna Waters the show is
directed by Mark Jones and Trey Miller
our production manager is Pablo vidoski
second assistant director Austin
mckellis the show is edited by Jeff
Tomlin Our lead audio engineer is Mike
cormina our hair makeup artist is
Cherokee heart our wardrobe stylist are
Kristen galaraga and Elizabeth Fox
director of production is Mathis Glover
director of Technology Mark Herman our
camera studio and equipment manager is
Patrick Kennedy our lighting director is
Keith Duggan host production manager
Matthew Kemp episode art is created by
Morgan Pierce our executive in charge of
production is David wermis executive
producer Jeremy Boren Matt Walsh show is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2023.
hey everybody this is Andrew klavan host
of the Andrew klavan show you know some
people are depressed because the
Republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the Moon's turn to
blood but on the Andrew klavan show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew klavan
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the Republic with me Andrew Clavin
[Music]